geld das ist ein elend zum heulen ist es
der schweizer spielfilm schwächelt und
will einfach nicht gesunden dem
sorgenkind wird tüchtig unter die arme
gegriffen und doch bleibt es
einigermaßen erfolglos von 100
kinogängern haben letztes jahr gerade
mal sechs einen schweizer kinofilm
besucht das sind wenig im vergleich zu
den europäischen nachbarn dänemark als
beispiel hier schauten immerhin 30 von
100 kinogängern einen film aus der
heimat
der däne feiert seinen film
im gegensatz zu uns findet schweizer
spielt grundsätzlich schlecht dann
schied er ganz wie zu filmen
wenn ich zuletzt von einer kluft
interessiert ich schaute er schon
ausländische filme schweizer filmen sind
wirklich schlimme sache
das läuft doch bekommen
naja spaßig schritt viel bein und etwas
exotik das bewegt noch nicht die großen
massen da fehlt noch etwas
unter anderem das liebe geld sagt er
der filmproduzent der die grossen
schweizer gästen macht filme machen
kostet ich bitte meine ich dass man
sollte weniger viel machen aber die
richtig finanziell so statistiken
richtig und sorgfältig gemacht werde man
sich im prinzip einig alle schweizer
film sind sozusagen unterfinanziert und
oft merkt man dass minder meinigen unser
fördersystem funktioniert in guter alter
demokratisch aus geborener mann ihr
jedem fläschchen sein wässerchen in der
bescheidene hoffnung auf den einen
starken fuchs jeder will so von fleisch
am knochen und letztendlich sind doch
alle irgendwie unzufrieden
die gießkanne in der hand laurent
steiert von der sektion film beim bund
beruft sich auf das helvetische dilemma
bezieht sich in regionen
das macht viel komplizierter natürlich
einheitliche filmförderung interessen
und andere sprache und die rechnung
tragen natürlich aber dadurch dass man
die sprache die ohnehin regionen
einerseits mehr verfällt aber andere
sind zum beispiel ich keine große
produktionsstätten und so bleiben wir
viel und kleinräumig föderalistisch
bürokratisch willig und unser film
bleibt harmloses mittelmaß das sagen sie
eine neu formierte gruppe
filmschaffender fordert ganz
unerschrocken je 300.000 franken sollen
zehn nachwuchsfilmer jährlich kriegen
aus einem sondertopf
ein blankoscheck als sprungbrett für
unsere künftigen oscar-preisträgerin mir
glaube darin liegt das riesenpotenzial
verbraucher zum kostengünstigen ähnlich
linien hersteller schweiz muss separat
zur großproduktion konnte sie dass
subventionen auftakt werden einfach so
machen mal und am historischen wirkliche
und wissen nicht einmal ein das stimmt
einfach nicht
ich finde ja die jungen trainer frage
wie viele bildeten russ r hd macht
überhaupt ihr lied
also ich das nicht eigentlich ein gutes
bild wo man von vornherein weiß dass
nachts prozent arbeitslos sie wird
tatsächlich verlassen hierzulande
jährlich 200 film schulabgänger die
schulbank
in dänemark werden an einer filmschule
nur 20 filmstudenten sehr gezielt
ausgebildet und in die filmkunst
eingeweiht fehlen in der schweiz die
starken leute die gute geschichten
schreiben mutige herausragende filme
nach den mystery ski 234 gemacht haben
um eine handschrift entwickeln wo
international relevanten präsidenten
kreuz denn wird der schweizer die
führung nach wie vor groß ob viele filme
für weniger geld oder weniger filme für
viel geld wir müssen die kinos füllen
mit dem schweizer
wer will denn schon da stehen wie ein
begossener pudel